لا تقدم على تهامه ترامب في حال لم تكن
متاكدا لانه اذا ثبتت براءه ترامب سيكتب
المؤرخين ان هذه القضيه اعادته الى البيت
الابيض رئيسا من الباب العريض ففي اخر
تطورات قضيه ترامب والممثله الاباحيه
الامريكيه قدم مستشار الامن القوميه
السابق للبيت الابيض جون بولتن نصيحه
لمدعي عام بعد تسريبات من مكتبه تتحدث عن
اعتقال ترامب يوم الثلاثاء القادم الرئيس
السابق ترامب كان سبق الاحداث ودعا انصاره
الى تنظيم احتجاجات لاستعاده الامه لمنع
اعتقاله وهذا الامر احدث ضجه في الداخل
الامريكي ومخاوف كبيره من ان يلجا انصار
ترامب الى العنف على غرار ما حصل في
السادس من يناير عام
2021 عندما اقتحم مناصروه مبنى الكونجرس
ونتج عنها طبعا فوضى كان يمكن ان تؤدي الى
حرب اهليه وهو ما حذر منه البيت الابيض
قبل نحو ساعتين من الان
وفي المقابله مع سي ان ان دع القضاء
الامريكي الى التاكد من صحه الاتهامات
وتاكد من انه اي القضاء سيدين ترامب مئه
بالمئه احتماله اعتقال ترامب دفع بقاده
جمهوريين الى الدفاع عنه وهو ما قام به
رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي الذي امر
بالتحقيق مع من يحقق مع ترامب وهو المدعي
العام الامريكي الشعب الامريكي له حق
دستوري في التجمع السلمي وعلى مناصري
ترامب الاحتجاج بطريقه سلميه هكذا علق
نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك بانس
على دعوه ترامب مناصريه للاحتجاج ليرد هنا
مدعي عام من هاتم بالقول حازما بانه ينصق
مع الشرطه نيويورك لحمايه المحققين من اي
تهديدات ولن يتسامح مع محاولات راب لتهديد
المحققين ولكن رب ما لن تبدا محاكمه ترامب
قبل اكثر من عام وقد تتزامن مع الاشهر
الختاميه للحمله الانتخابيه لرئاسه البيت
الابيض في عام 2024 والتي يسعى فيها ترامب
للعوده طبعا الى المكتب البيضاوي يقول هنا
الخبراء الحقوقين
كيف تؤثر مشكلات ترامب القانونيه على
مساعيه للرئاسه في 2024
دستوريا لم تحدد اي ماده الاتهامات او
الادانات الجنائيه التي تطال مؤهلات
الرئيس
زمنيا ربما يضطر ترامب للمثول للمحاكمه في
منتصف حملته الرئاسيه او حتى بعد
الانتخابات
اي قضيه جنائيه تستغرق اكثر من عام لتتحول
من مجرد اتهامات الى محاكمه اذا جرى
انتخاب ترامب لن يتمتع بسلطه العفو عن
نفسه في اتهامات موجهه بموجب قانون ولايه
لكن احاله الرئيس المنتخب للمحاكمه ستدخل
حينها حيزا قانونيا مجهولا